well so so my
my big unified theory on social media is
i'm very i'm very bearish
yes on the big platforms having a long
future
you are i think the moment i think the
moment of three or four major platforms
is uh not gonna last right so
i don't know okay this is just
perspective right so you can start
shorting these stocks uh
on my don't sell it's not financially
yeah yeah don't do robinhood
um so here's here's i think the the big
mistake the major platforms made
as when they they took out the network
effect advantage
right so the original pitch especially
something like facebook or instagram
was the people you know are on here
right so like
what you use this was you can connect to
people that you already know this is
what makes the network useful
we so therefore the value of our network
grows uh quadratically with the number
of users and therefore
it's such a head start that there's no
way that someone else can catch up
but when they shifted and when facebook
took the lead of say we're going to
shift towards a news feed model
they basically said we're going to try
to in the moment get more data and get
more likes like what we're going to go
towards is actually just
seeing interesting stuff like scene
diverting information so people took
this social
internet impulse to connect to people
digitally to other tools
like group text messages and whatsapp
and stuff like this right so you don't
think about these tools as oh this is
where i connect with people
once it's just a feed that's kind of
interesting now you're competing with
everything else that can produce
interesting content that's diverting
i think that is a much fiercer
competition because now for example
you're going up against podcast
right i mean like okay i guess you know
the twitter feed is interesting right
now but also a podcast is interesting or
something else could be interesting too
i think it's a much fiercer competition
when there's no
there's no more network effects right
and so my sense is we're going to see a
fragmentation into what i call long tail
social media
where if i don't need everyone i know to
be on a platform then why not have
three or four bespoke platforms i use
where it's a thousand people
and it's all we're all interested in you
know whatever
ai or comedy and it we've perfected this
interface and maybe it's like clubhouse
it's audio or something and
we all pay two dollars so we don't have
to worry about attention harvesting
and that's going to be wildly more
entertaining i mean i'm thinking about
comedians on twitter
it's not the best internet possible
format for them
expressing themselves and being
interesting that you have all these
comedians that are trying to like well i
can do like little clips and little
whatever like i don't know if there was
a
long tail social media that's really
this is where the comedians are and this
podcast
and the comedians are on podcast now so
this is my thought is that there's
really no
there's really no strong advantage to
having one
large platform that everyone is on
if all you're getting from it is i now
have different options for diversion and
like uplifting aspirational or whatever
types of entertainment
that whole thing could fragment and i
think the glue that was holding together
was network effects i don't think they
realized that when network effects have
been destabilized
they don't have the centrifugal force
anymore and they're spinning faster and
faster but is is a twitter feed really
that much more interesting than all
these streaming services is it really
that much more interesting
than clubhouse is it that much more
interesting than podcast
i feel like they don't realize how
unstable their ground actually is yeah
that's fascinating but
uh the thing that makes twitter and
facebook
work i mean the the news feed you're
exactly right like that you can just
duplicate the news like if
it's not the social network and it's the
news feed then why not have multiple
different
feeds that are more that are better at
satisfying there's a dopamine
gamification that they've figured out
yeah the and
uh you so you have to whatever you
create
you have to at least provide some
pleasure in that same gamification kind
of way
it doesn't have to have to do with scale
of large social networks but
i mean i guess you're implying that you
should be able to design that kind of
uh mechanism in other forms or people
are turning on the that gamification
i mean so people are getting wise to it
and are getting uncomfortable about it
right so if i'm offering something
there these existing sugar people
realize sugar is bad
yeah drinking a lot's great too but it
also after a while you realize there's
there's problems so some of the long
tail social media networks that are out
there that i've looked at
they offer usually like a deeper sense
of connection like
it's usually interesting people that you
share some affinity and you have these
carefully cultivated
i wrote this new yorker piece a couple
years ago about the indie social media
movement that really
got into some of these different
technologies but i think the
technologies are a distraction
we focus too much on you know mastodon
versus you know whatever like forget
or discord like actually let's forget
the protocols right now it's the idea
of okay and there's all a lot of these
long tail social media groups what
people are getting out of it which i
think can
outweigh the dopamine gamification is
strong connection and motivation like
you're in a group with other guys that
are all trying to be
you know better dads or something like
this and and you talk to them on a
regular basis and you're sharing your
stories and there's interesting talks
and
that's a powerful thing too one
interesting thing about scale of twitter
is you have these viral spread of
information
so sort of uh twitter has become a
newsmaker in itself
yeah that's the problem well yes but i
wonder what replaces that
because because then you immediately
reported
no the problem with reporters and
journalism is that they're
they're intermediary they have control
i mean this is the problem in russia
currently is that you have
um it creates a shield between the the
people and
news the the interesting thing and the
powerful thing about twitter
is that the news originates from the
individual that's creating the news like
you you have the president united the
former president of the united states on
twitter creating news you have
elon musk creating news you have people
announcing stuff
on twitter as opposed to talking to a
journalist and that feels
much more genuine and uh
it's it feels very powerful but actually
coming to realize it it
it doesn't need the social network you
can just put that announcement on a
youtube type of thing this is what i'm
thinking right so this is my point about
that because that's right it it
the the democratizing power of the
internet is fantastic i'm i'm an
old-school
internet nerd a guy that was you know
telnetting in the servers and gophering
before the world wide web was around
right so i'm a huge internet booster and
that's that's one of its big power
but when you put everything on twitter i
think the fact that you've taken
uh you homogenized everything right so
everything looks the same
moves with the same low friction it's
very difficult you have no what i call
distributed curation
right the only curation that really
happens there's a little bit with likes
and also the algorithm
but if you look back to pre web 2.0 or
early web 2.0 when a lot of this was
happening let's say on blogs
where people own their own servers and
you had your different blogs
there was this distributed curation that
happened where in order for
your blog to get on people's radar and
this had nothing to do with any
gatekeepers or legacy media it was over
time you got more links and people
respected you and you would hear about
this blog over here and there's this
whole distributed curation and filtering
going on
so if you think like the 2004
presidential election uh
most of the information people gained
from the internet one of the first big
internet
news driven elections was from you know
you had like the daily costs and
and drudge but there was like blogs that
were out there and this was back ezra
klein was just running a blog out of his
uh
you know a dorm room at this point right
and you would in a distributed fashion
gain credibility because okay
i people have paid it it's very hard to
get people to pay attention to blog
they're paying attention i get linked to
this kid ezra or whatever it seems to be
really sharp and now people are noticing
it
and now you have a distributed curation
that solves a lot of the problems we see
when you have a completely homogenized
low friction environment like friction
where
i mean twitter where any random
conspiracy theory or whatever that
people like can just
shoot through and spread whereas if
you're starting a blog
to try to push q anon or something like
that
it's probably going to be a really weird
looking vlog you're going to have a hard
time like it's just never going to show
up on people's radar right i mean
so everything you've said up until the
very last statement i would i would
agree with
this is a topic i don't know a ton about
i guess there's uh
i think i'll forget q anon uh
but gyonan is yeah could be that i also
don't know i should
know more i apologize i don't know more
i mean that's the power
and uh the downside you can have
i mean hitler could have a blog today
yeah
and you would have potentially very
large following if he's charismatic if
he's
has you know is good with words he's
able to express the ideas whatever maybe
he's able to channel
the frustration the anger that people
have about a certain thing and
so i think that's the power of blogs but
it's also the
limitation but that doesn't we're not
trying to solve that you can't solve
that yeah the fundamental problem you're
saying is not the problem
the your your thesis is that there's
nothing special about
large-scale social networks that
guarantees that they will keep
existing and it's important to remember
for a lot of the older generation of
internet
activists or the people who are very
pro-internet in the early days
they were completely flabbergasted by
the rise of these
platforms say what why would you take
the internet and then build your own
version of the internet
where you own all the servers and we
built this whole distribute the whole
thing with open protocols
uh everyone anywhere in the world use
the same protocols your machine can talk
to any other machine it's the most
democratic communication system that's
ever been built and then these companies
came along and said we're going to build
our own
we'll just own all the servers and put
them in buildings that we own and the
internet will just be the first mile
this gets you into our private internet
where we
own the whole thing it went completely
against the entire
motivation of the internet was like yes
we it's not going to be one person owns
all the servers and you pay to access
them it's any one
server that they own can talk to anyone
else's server because we all agree on a
standard set of
protocols and so the the old guard of
pro internet people
never understood this move towards let's
build
private versions of the internet uh
we'll build three or four private
internets and that's what we'll all use
it was the opposite basically well it's
funny enough i don't know if you follow
but jack dorsey is also
uh as a proponent and is helping to fund
create fully distributed versions of
twitter essentially
that would potentially destroy twitter
yeah but i think there
you know there might be financial art
like business cases to be made there i'm
not sure
but that seems to be another alternative
as as opposed to creating a bunch of
uh like the long tail uh creating like
the ultimate long tail of like fully
distributed
yeah which is which is what the internet
is but that's that's sort of like
i'm thinking about long tail social
media i'm thinking it's uh like the
tech's not so important
like there's groups out there right i i
know where
the tech they use to actually implement
their digital only social group whatever
they might use slack they might use some
combination of zoomer it doesn't matter
i think in the tech world
we want to build the beautiful protocol
right that okay everyone's going to use
as just a
federated server protocol in which we've
worked out x y and z and no one
understands it because then the
engineers need it all to make i get it
because i'm a nerd like this like okay
every standard has to fit with
everything else and no one understands
what's going on
meanwhile you know you have this group
of bike enthusiasts they're like yeah
we'll just
jump on a zoom and have some slack and
put up a blog the tech doesn't really
matter
like we've built the world with our own
curation our own rules
uh our own sort of social ecosystem
that's generating a lot of value
i mean i don't know if it'll happen
there's a lot of money at stake with
obviously these large
but i just think they're more they're so
i mean look how quickly
americans left facebook right i mean
facebook was savvy to buy other
properties in the
diversify right but how quick did that
take for just standard facebook news
yeah everyone under the age of something
we're using it and no one under a
certain age is using it now it took like
four years i mean this stuff is
really i believe you people can leave
facebook overnight
yeah like i i think uh facebook hasn't
actually messed up
f like enough to there's two things they
haven't messed up enough for people to
really leave aggressively and there's no
good alternative
for them to leave i think if good
alternatives pop up
it would just immediately happen this
stuff is a lot more culturally fragile i
think
i mean twitter's having a moment because
it was feeding a certain type of i mean
there's a lot of anxieties that was in
the the sort of
political sphere anyways that twitter
was working with
um but its moment could go to as well i
mean it's a really arbitrary thing
short little things and i read a wired
article about this earlier in the
pandemic like this is crazy
that the way that we're trying to
communicate information about the
pandemic is
all these weird arbitrary rules where
people are screen shotting
pictures of articles that are part of a
tweet thread where you say one slash
n under it like we have the technology
guys yeah
to like really clearly convey in for
long form information to people like
why are we why do we have these and i
know it's because it's the gamified
dopamine hits but
what a weird medium there's no reason
for us to have to
have these threads that you have to find
and pin will you screenshot i mean we
have technology to communicate better
using the internet i mean
why are epidemiologists having to do
tweet threads
well because there's mechanisms of
publishing that make it easier on
twitter
i mean we're evolving as a species and
the internet is a very
fresh thing yeah and so it's kind of
interesting to think
that as opposed to twitter this is what
jack also complains about
is twitter's not innovating fast enough
yeah and
so it's almost like the people are
innovating and thinking about
their productive life faster than the
platforms in which they operate can
catch up
yeah and so at the point you the gap
grows
sufficiently they'll jump a few people a
few innovative folks will just create
an alternative and perhaps distributed
uh
perhaps just many little silos
and then people will jump and then we'll
just continue this kind of way but see i
think like sub stack for example what
they're going to pull out of twitter
among other things is the audience that
was
let's say like slightly left of sinner
but
um slateless slender don't like trump
uncomfortable with like post-modern
critical theories made into
political action right and they're like
yeah twitter there's a people on there
talking about this and it made me feel
sort of hurt because i was feeling a
little bit like a nerd about it but
honestly i'd probably rather subscribe
the four subs you know i'm gonna have
like
berries and andrew sullivan i'll have
like a jesse signals like i'll have a
few
sub stacks i can subscribe to and
honestly that's i'm a knowledge worker
who's
32 anyways probably that's an email all
day and and so like there's an
innovation that's going to that group
you know it's going to suck them off
which is actually a very large group
yeah that's a lot of that's a lot of
energy and then once trump's gone i
guess that's probably going to drive
that drove a lot of uh
more like trump people off twitter like
this stuff is fragile i
think i but the fascinating thing to me
because i've hung out on parlor for
a short amount enough to to know that
the interface matters it's so
fascinating like that
it's not just about ideas yeah it's
about
creating like sub stack to creating a
pleasant experience
uh addicting experience oh you're right
you're right about that and it's hard
and that's why this is one of the
conclusions from that indie social media
article
is it's just the ugliness matters and i
don't mean even just aesthetically but
just the clunkiness of the interfaces
the
um and i don't know it's to some degree
the social media companies have spent a
lot of money on this
and to some degree it's a survivorship
bias yeah right i think
twitter every time i hear jack talks
about this it seems like
he's as surprised as anyone else the way
twitter's being used i mean it's
basically
the way you know they had it uh
years ago and then you know it was like
great it'll be statuses right
yeah this is what i'm doing you know and
my friends can follow me and see it and
without really changing anything it just
happened to hit everything right
yeah to support this other type of
interaction well there's also the
javascript model which
brendan ike talked about he just
implemented javascript
uh like the crappy version of javascript
in 10 days threw it out there and just
uh changed it really quickly yeah
involved it really quickly and now has
become according to stack exchange the
most popular programming language in the
world
yeah it drives like most of the internet
and even the back end and now mobile and
yeah and so that that's an argument for
the kind of thing you're talking about
where like
like the bike club people yeah could
literally
create the thing that would uh you know
run most of the internet
you know 10 years from now yeah it's so
there's something to that like
as opposed to trying to get lucky or
trying to think through stuff it's just
to uh
to solve a particular problem do stuff
yeah and do stuff do something like
keep tinkering until you love it yeah
yeah and then uh
and of course the sad thing is timing
and luck matter
and that you can't really control that's
the problem yeah
you